hello my friends oh my gosh so it has
been quite a while since I got the Apple
watch Ultra which I'm absolutely loving
I thought that this watch was going to
be too big it is pretty massive
especially on my tiny wrist but I have
gotten so incredibly used to it now one
of the tips that I found for me first of
all that it was super helpful was I
flipped the action button to be closer
to my hand because dial kept hitting my
wrist bone so I couldn't actually use
the dial because I kept like it was
jamming into my wrist and it didn't feel
great so now that I have flipped this
just like this it's been amazing like I
have been running miles and miles and
miles I took this thing on my trip to
Indonesia which I don't think I've
actually posted that video yet I haven't
finished editing it I went to this
incredible island called Zumba and the
resort was called nihi and I've never
been anywhere cooler like it was just
absolutely so fantastic but I got to
really take this Apple watch out on
adventures into the ocean into this
amazing place called this blue waterfall
and as you guys know if you've watched
any of my videos before you know that I
don't like to swim I thought that I
couldn't swim but this place kind of
showed me that I kind of knew how to
swim I swam out to this blue waterfall
with the Apple watch on to get the water
temperature I was like oh okay so I
guess maybe I can swim but either way I
have been wearing this Apple watch and
not worrying about it because it feels
so much more industrial than my other
Apple watches I was going in the pool I
was going on the ocean before I would
have never done that with my old Apple
watch even though I know it could handle
it there's just something about this
that feels so much more rugged so much
more durable I feel like in the initial
kind of marketing and showcasing this
Apple watch they were showcasing it in
such a way that people were going out on
these excursions these ridiculously
crazy hikes scuba diving all of these
things and I don't really feel like
that's the case like anybody could
benefit from this people working in
construction people who are just doing
kind of more Hands-On intensive things
and not having to
work you go on vacation that you're out
swimming in a blue waterfall or
whatever it is doing just I really love
it like I've been loving it more than I
ever thought I would even with the
action button being able to just click
that I have that set up to go to my
workouts I've never run in a race before
but I recently did a 5K race for
Halloween which was so fun I wasn't
racing to be like actually winning
because my training is not quite up to
par but I had such a fun time doing that
and it really kind of made me think as a
runner how can I start using the Apple
watch to help benefit that and with a
lot of the new running features I'm
super excited to test that out in the
latest watch OS so I also have with me
here which I got a couple of weeks ago
but I did get a chance to open it the
new Trail band so I actually switched
this to just one of the sport Loop bands
I did really like the Alpine Loop it
felt very safe like I did not feel like
going out in the ocean doing these hikes
and all the things that I was doing with
it while I was on vacation I did not
feel afraid that it was going to fall
off my wrist now this also feels you
know pretty secure but because the
Alpine Loop has those little Loops it
felt like it was not going anywhere I
did not actually wear the ocean watch
band in the ocean just because I had the
Alpine on already so the Alpine
definitely did get me through a lot of
Adventures but this is what I've been so
excited to actually try out because I
saw this at the Apple event and when I
tried this on it's a different type of
material it's much thinner so let's open
it up and check it out
I think I'm gonna have to order the blue
one as well because that one also looks
really great so here it is so you can
already see how thin this is especially
in comparison visibly to the eye it
doesn't really look that thin but when
you feel it
it is much thinner
so I don't know if you guys can tell
but it's definitely thinner yeah this
looks great oh I'm so excited
the one problem that I have been having
is because my wrist is so small a lot of
these larger watch bands that I have for
the 45 millimeter they basically wrap
all the way around to like the top of my
wrist so it's not really perfect but
with this it seems like it's a little
bit smaller so so I'm able to
have a much thinner band oh my God I
love it so much I absolutely love it so
here's what it looks like
we've got this nice little pull tab and
it's super light I love that it's
lightweight so I have this set up as so
that I can click my iPhone timer I've
got my Apple watch rings set up so I can
see if I need to close them I could
probably remove this workout button
since I now have the action button so
I'm gonna have to find a replacement for
that what's this one that's nice nice
Starlight so yeah basically my thoughts
of having the Apple watch Ultra for the
past couple of months I love it I even
bought the Apple Watch series 8 just
thinking that I would maybe want to swap
and switch them I don't really wear it
to sleep because I do have my aura rings
so I haven't really got into sleeping
with the Apple watch this is the New
Horizon one rose gold yes please I know
a lot of the new health benefits really
can only be taken advantage of if you do
sleep with your Apple watch and for
whatever reason I just really don't like
sleeping with it so that's why I do like
wearing the aura ring so I do like being
able to have both of these work together
like they really do work so great
together because I'm able to track my
more precise runs my activities all on
my Apple watch and that will all sync to
the aura Ring app so this is like a
sleep tracker but it does do some in-app
Fitness tracking as well but I do love
using my Apple watch so much so I love
being able to use both of these together
so yeah that's just kind of an update on
how I'm liking the Apple watch Ultra I'd
love to hear from you guys if you've had
the same experiences I really haven't
had any trouble with it at all I've just
been mostly surprised how much I really
really like it because I thought for
sure how large this was I was going to
get annoyed with it I'd have to take it
off during the day and I haven't had any
of those problems the battery life also
is just beyond anything that I could
ever expect like there's some nights
that I don't charge it I don't even
worry about it the entire trip that I
took to Indonesia it was about a 34 hour
travel day I put this in the low power
sleep mode and I made it the entire
travel with some to spare actually a lot
to spare like I could have went the rest
of that day without out even having to
worry about charging it so it was really
cool to kind of get that real life
experience of when what I really need to
use that that's it I would love to hear
from you guys though if you got one do
you want one do you know anyone that has
one I'd love to hear from you in the
comments below and with that I will see
you guys in my next video if you haven't
already please subscribe hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and I
look forward to seeing you guys in the
comments below I'll see you in the next
one bye
thank you